(upbeat music)
- We always like to finish things up
with something cool and
fun that's trending,
this is "What I'm Liking".
(upbeat guitar music)
(audience clapping)
Things can get a little intense in life,
and we all need some comic relief,
and that's where our next guest comes in.
His new Netflix special is called,
"Deon Cole Charleen's Boy"
and it's streaming now.
The entire special is a tribute
to Deon's late mom, Charleen,
and we have him on the line right now
to tell us more;
What's up Deon?
(audience cheering)
- Hey, how you doing?
- I'm so good,
but I'm sad you're not here in person;
I always love when you come.
You make me so happy, man.
You're just one of those people,
you're so infectious.
(Deon laughing)
- I wish I could be there.
I'm down here in Atlanta shooting
this new show called
"Average Joe", man so-
- [Kelly] Ah.
- We doing what we do, you know?
- Absolutely, absolutely.
Well, it's great to see you,
and I'm so sorry for your loss.
This is actually...
You filmed this
is it one year to the day
after you lost your mom?
- Yeah, so my mom had passed
on September 10th, 2021,
and I had...
Netflix was like,
"Yo, we want you to shoot a special",
but I had toured everywhere already.
The only place I didn't tour was New York,
and I was like, "Yeah,
we'll find out the date",
and I knew my mom had passed on.
This was her first year anniversary,
which would've been September 10th,
and I didn't want to work
nowhere around that date,
so I made sure that I
told them to find a place
towards the end of September,
and they just came across me like,
"Man, don't mourn her, celebrate her,"
like, "Let her live forever
through what you do.
That's how when we lose people,
they live through us",
and so I was like, "Man, you know what?
I'm just going to shoot it
on that day that she passed,
and call it "Charleen's Boy",
because it'll be a double entendre."
It'll be who I am,
and it'll be the name of the special,
so when people say,
"Have you seen "Charleen's Boy?"
It'll be basically speaking about her,
and so I shot that whole special
without the audience even knowing
that this was the anniversary
of her first death,
and so when I told them at the end,
it resonated with a lot of people and-
- Absolutely.
- And I just tried to tell everybody like,
"Yeah, you just never know
what a person is going through,
and embrace those that have lost somebody,
because they're not the same,
and quit treating them the same,
'cause they're not."
- Thank you so much, Deon.
You're literally one
of my favorite guests that comes here,
and it's because whatever
you are going through,
you're so honest about it,
and that is so healing,
probably for you,
but also all those people,
you're saying that watch this,
and it healed them as well,
and they connected in a different way.
Had you not been so open,
that might not have happened,
and you know, you probably reached
so many people that needed that.
- Kelly, thank you so much
for sharing your platform
with so many people.
You are such a blessing to everybody,
and I want to thank you
from the bottom of my
heart as well, definitely.
- Thank you.
It's literally like my favorite thing.
I always say it's like
the dream job I never knew I wanted,
and thank you, Deon.
We love you so much.
I can't wait to see you.
Come promote
whatever you're working
on right now in person,
'cause I miss you.
Okay.
I'm liking your post right now.
- [Deon] Alright, thank you.
(Kelly and audience clapping)
(heart dinging)
Thank you so much, love you.
- Oh man.
I love him so much.
He's so cool.
Everybody be sure to watch
"Deon Cole Charleen's Boy",
streaming now on Netflix.
So here's the thing:
we've hit the time in the show
when we usually give our guest $1,000,
thanks to our season-long partner,
Pilot Pen, makers of G2,
the go-to pen of "The
Kelly Clarkson Show",
but come on, Deon's doing all right.
He's got food in his pantry.
He's all right.
He doesn't need the $1,000 so
(Kelly laughing)
we thought we're going to give it
to someone in the audience.
How does that sound?
(audience cheering)
Anybody want it?
Alright.
Well, look under your chairs,
(suspenseful music)
'cause someone in this audience
has a $1,000 check taped under it.
(drumming music)
(audience chatting)
(upbeat rock music)
Oh.
(Kelly clapping)
Stand up.
(audience clapping)
What's your name?
- Kara.
- [Kelly] Your name is Kara?
- Yeah.
- First of all, you have
bouncy commercial hair.
It's great.
Let's lead with that, Kara.
So what do you think
you'll do with the money?
- Maybe go on a trip, I don't know.
- I love it.
Everybody usually says pay bills.
Yes, Kara.
- I could probably do that.
- Have fun with it.
(Kelly laughing and clapping)
Well, thank you, Kara, for being here.
Have so much fun with that money,
and thank you to all our guests this hour:
Andie MacDowell, Whitney
Peak, Brad Meltzer,
Scarlett Johansson, Lawrence Aaron.
Y'all have a great day,
and if it's not, well, try and change it.